oh I could choose if I the Jews one let
it choose in the area in which I've
written you know quite a bit and torture
quite a bit it's not about I mean it's
not globalization there is a week
underbelly as it were and that is to do
with capital flows it's in my book on in
defense of globalization I have a
separate chapter or non capital flows
capital flows we still really don't know
in an interdependent system where
capital can move very fast what we can
do is suddenly panic materializes right
now in fact as we talk there's still
there we are on edge right as a result
of subprime lending and so on in
international capital flows there's
always this continuous anxiety no matter
what people say in public involvement as
to whether one day something will break
up the system and there's no way to to
feel completely secure about and that is
something I wrote in the time of the
east asian financial crisis in foreign
affairs and it was called the capital
myth and i was simply saying that with
trade of course they can be problems but
the minor problems like if I exchange my
toothbrush for your toothpaste you know
if you put surplus away and if we
remember to brush our teeth we would
both look brother good right and the
probability of our teeth being knocked
out in the process of exchange is rather
small the nothing can be ruled out in
life but with with the analogy for
capital flows is like with fire fire can
be used if convenor turns raw meat into
a wonderful steak or some but it can
also burn your house down and that is
the worry and I think we really haven't
Scotch that I don't know where
one ever can and that remains today with
very rapid flows of capital possible
with people continuously playing and
people screw unscrupulously following
advantage I mean like for instance
George Soros was asked you know why did
you bet against a Malaysian currency you
remember village you know Martha was mad
as hell so mad that he even made some
anti-semitic slurs which are totally
uncalled for makers like I don't even
know if your sources are practicing Jew
it wasn't rid of it it was such a crazy
thing to say but he had a point about
Joe source himself you don't leave my
currency alone and sir george soros has
eventually said look I believe there
should be controlled like internal
capital flows are a problem but as long
as they're possible I'm gonna make money
all right now that many people who don't
care George cares but it's you know if
there's money to be made here make it
until the system changes and the rest of
us so I think this is this I do worry
about and I I this is the most important
problem because multinational
investments trade even migration we are
beginning to learn how to handle that
and I think some of the evolution
thinking there is where we want to
manage it between sending hundreds of
receiving countries mining is moving in
the right direction in my view and an
international patents and so on and you
know letting generic drugs develop that
has also moved a long way so the only
place where I don't really I don't think
anybody could reassure me actually and I
because it's not possible right now all
we can do is whistle in the dark and
hope nothing will happen which is
exactly where we are at on the emerging
crisis which I hope will disappear but
it's only a hope it's not an expense
you